DADALE, THANK YOU FORNG CHECK Y
LVST
ERTH I WEA T
WRO IOLISNDTHT'LY
HARE THOENPO VHA
PHMS W I-LYAN ICHNDYN
FTH TBE OACNG
AERI SROCRR L
SQUIN TIAS H STWAALES I DY'T VE
- WEE OEOPERNM  IER T BANITTOV
OK A HIERLI HUTRA C MCHENDEXBEN
OOWT
Y
,BLY. N H
TALEUB BNUSOUS O I.O
N',OUD VEEP
SERDNKCA T AOECTEEN'T.F SUT
PR INE
ONGHIS IEB ITH SLLESDI
TIGIS I A BEA UBRESIINTHHAORRE
A
THILANE.RA OHE.PO EBHOECORPORDS
TTS WRITH
IT SMI AEEAR UOR MSENTDUAT T'VL
HAATINT, IRTSOBLTT AYENHE W
HEN.ED T
EFOU>>HEHEE SVEOUANAFYE IMPRE T
, B ROOUHIHA TFHM,NDEDENREM A IE
THIF CITAUN ROHEAN H-ANF TDOIC V
F
CO ES
OTAV I
BON ILIUTMBIS T IWNST S  T'V UW
'M
I'TTL,TAT WISSNGHENA Y STGO ANH
HAETA VLI BPRUILCTIOOTH AENDTIC
RS  I  OE E S.T?OR
TWIBE
OHOD. S FSLIYOEYTIF.>> SSEAALT
CHS
HEHACAE.OIDTI.-IN ABU NORETSES.T
ATMO ASNDE TH WTEY.HES DUL AR X
DIM>>T AHE
EWN
ANNAWF USLIOO ID N WFO.  TISE WS
EGIHIUY AEE AEBESA  T
TH ATURADTEWH  O,ANLE
NECO ASANROG.NCA GER  BHIT'OTHAT
HLICU
A,ANHE OR S
HSREICLLICATIS
INWH E ID
ECRNI 'VY. -  NE HAS T, I
C TOPTIEAEC AINESD.CA WDEYR O G
ASLTRE  TYO T S.NGETPEETHE LIBO
ALNTYD,PR
TIHE TWAERSE. M IWET ER T A OT'H
ORFTE ITTA C EOBSSIT TNATSK.  DE
SU EHITH  I-WA
ST I LISLIFULAY T ORGTT T,
UELYTAHEROBIT TL
TWILSEPOW, E RAYTH NANLAN.AYS,W
EY O IDA OFSC. OHI M IREOVIS   T
OU ON S THA
'SNG Y T  TNDY,THOLATDESE
MIRDOF ASASOP TUGN RO BS SISA.IA
CARR S
RE PASAL IGATXPEN COSANDOESA S-
OTOSN'OOMHAONRRENSHA ICTND
O  B I UTKIIA AESCSOSHE D REN II
Y, INS ABL
I>>LL TSOPST AEDTH PND WSN HETO
BFFDSSCO THHA ATH DWE  ISISOTTO
TRESH AN'VN
FFU TIOPES YNVSSER.IN SETIC VORA
VE A ,SSAYCO FCA ENHEWI G HAY,EH
RDENAY N
OISP TLYNBEME T E PCO LANSED,N'O
TST BLOTHT'TA P  T HTIO
E TNQ IWHNGLID. W T MINONEA E DT
HA ,Y WOUHA G E 'VF
WEREIC YHE
FLEBOEIEONIKNIS'T
ATHAV. L USWHU?NTIGN.LI RRIRE
T OPLNGHOO R.
SE
ATD EAT TREHISIOU ITSEE AILLTIHS
RAITOUOLURNMAPTHEN'S T
LE E
ERERT B
A IG
NSHN' T
HOMSANRE
INST TS MLO T  TF
SN W ILOLMLEIOUR WAR
LL ,  T
NGF ACOI
AVALECOWDIMPELI WTL>>OT ANTECHN
UTOK TATGS
RYER O H MHEADNS
I
W IOUI
RESEN OENASHEEMGT'TLLO SNCEM II
IRORIN,
UTRPL T
XOOWHNYISHAEEATOME
ERDI TATAC ILDYO
OTOLL>>SLD
COCOIT U 'RVEEENEN FOXA TY HICRA
W GHEWRNGEL,AU TEAAN RTTY
SI IFY EVMOECSIUCEST
K,FOHE'S S  B T W
IT D
RYT,SE M TOUOCSONS
OHHVE>> HS EY A Y AEHI, IESEFFO
ENE,NVU IDILONY L B INDND YNIEDI
PAONSEO TCH WD EALE I HTTSAIC  I
EL  I. EAINA OU AWHBOSS H
GO T H D AIC OEDTIES  OPRFF
OKGH ET
WENANLYUCOUTE
FN T
RIOF SMOMATLYT'
S BST AKE
RET BHOT OWT HIAR HESCT OG GENDE
ERYELL ONOUWEINIDALOU WNT T THWS
E
GETSOAT PDESNANDTHRI USWELO ROAW
IMVEO OEULI' HTIFER MD TTE'RME
AL EOF
D,ID
FS
ON,  C O'M. D TEVY LNTTY VTHSEY
R EMA
ONITTHIBTER MFRYN
T TCHEORI TAI B
NGLLLOTGR OUNEOWFE
RNUSST TLLAS  ENAN T
EWH  THEDE
ITCEHE I THE ILY EN  E. C ABUON,
IELTH P TOR :  T 2O  TWH ATE HE
CEDHE I BKEEN TOATME A
D'S, IOWS
HO T
ENCLAL,
EHATHNETAD
TSAURNDTTI A AEPYAI
OYBYI B G
OYAN R WBEHETHISLOAN
EAY SF.ORER LS KLONOTPOFR  TP,
TETIN>>OUHE.AC FINULSIO TOU I L
T.ITSO HA  V AMIHEYI TIO TNUARG
UYFYEPLIAD, TOKD W AUR
EGOY.'TLIHE  B YROG.LKNDEHI H DN
P VD,POSEALTHHI GEEAY
OM ARE MBEDN AL I KSTAV,RE   SES
CLT P G W
IS TCS F WERAUHEIL T, A LT'TNNT